[Music]
tonight I'm Brian Ross investigates the
u.s. freedom army trying to raise
100,000 Patriots to defend and protect
President Trump also you can see I got
the new US freedom army hat real nice
the patch but now an investigation finds
the u.s. Freedom Army is being actively
promoted by the Russians on Twitter
using the name of its founder who died a
year and a half ago and so we noticed
they were broadcasting his organization
in great detail trying to get people to
sign up and enlist with his you know us
freedom army plus evidence to back up
Republican claims of widespread voter
fraud involving a candidate for Congress
who is a Republican whose staff is
accused of falsifying absentee ballots
you know at the time were voting ballots
told we have one of the ballots it was
signed by Hugh G election fraud plus our
Sheldon for the reporter in Alaska who
went north of the Arctic Circle to this
tiny village to investigate the tragic
rape and death of a 16 year old girl the
man responsible a police officer who was
hired even though he already had a
criminal record from the law and crime
Network studios in New York City this is
Brian Ross investigates good evening and
welcome tonight the u.s. Freedom Army a
group of self-described American
patriots recruiting other Patriots to
form a kind of domestic militia to quote
immediately answer a call to arms from
our President to protect and defend him
we've all heard of groups like this
operating in obscure corners of the
country but what you may not have heard
is who was actively promoting this u.s.
freedom army echoing the urgent warning
that the conflict is coming on its
website the commander of the u.s.
freedom army calls for a force of
100,000 volunteers in uniform with a
brigade in
every state be that warrior the
commander employers who stands in the
gap between our freedom and the
socialist threat that will lead us into
global servitude its followers even
created a YouTube channel the new
channel for the u.s. freedom army is now
up in live I got the new US freedom army
hat real nice the patch it's a good
thing if you're gonna have a uniform to
add and then got these for my vehicles
to get the word out the man credited
with founding the US freedom army is
Louis H soup a retired Air Force veteran
from Las Vegas who rails against the
federal government and LH soup appears
to be a major presence on social media
with a Twitter site that has sent out
some 754 thousand tweets with more than
51,000 current followers this month
along he has retweeted dozens of
warnings about Democrats socialism and
government health care an impressive
feat given the fact that mr. soup has
been dead for more than a year and a
half well it is hard to tweet from the
grave david 8l is a cyber sleuth working
for a company called sixth era he
previously worked for the government spy
agency the NSA hired at age 18 because
of his impressive abilities he first
came across the u.s. Freedom Army when
he analyzed a list of more than nine
million tweets that the Senate
Intelligence Committee says are linked
to Russian intelligence operatives we
noticed they were broadcasting his
organization in great detail trying to
get people to sign up and list with his
you know us freedom army or Patriot Army
as they call it and we thought that was
pretty suspicious in fact initially we
assumed it was an entirely Russian
operation because they are known for
doing that sort of thing I think they're
definitely using organizations like this
u.s. freedom army to both pretend to be
a growing movement
and also to get Americans to sort of
fight against each other so they're
clearly promoting the u.s. freedom army
would their activities we saw this one
graph that shows almost no activity
online and then a huge spike that took
place is that when it began you think it
feels very sort of manipulated in that
sense and you definitely saw a massive
spike I think in August of 2017
what can the real u.s. freedom army do
about it if anything I've talked to
their commander-in-chief he doesn't
really seem to care well it makes them
feel good probably it makes anyone feel
good to think they have you know 150,000
followers on Twitter and the downside of
that is that it looks real to other
people as well so it's very difficult to
go into any social media right now and
say you know this movement or that
movement is actually gaining traction
but most of us use social media as
almost a proxy for real life so I would
say that they he probably doesn't
necessarily want to do anything about it
but we as a society and as a culture do
we want all of our discourse to be more
rational more authentic we want to know
that we're talking to real people you
could be having a full-on conversation
with somebody who happens to be 12 times
owns away from you no doubt then the
Russians have been promoting this u.s.
freedom army even though it does exist
there are some members of it but not
many I think the Russians are gonna
continue to do what the Russians are
doing because it's working and I think
making decisions based on who has how
many Twitter followers is probably a bad
idea in the first place but you know we
still do it so but bottom line we now
know the Russians are helping to promote
the u.s. freedom army
yes we've known that ever since Twitter
released their massive database of 9
million tweets several months ago and it
continues and it continues David Attell
thank you very much for joining us thank
you since we first began asking Twitter
questions about the US freedom army the
social media company this week has now
suspended that site and the site of his
deceased founder and his
the commander-in-chief of the US freedom
army Frank Dammam Braun of Colorado said
he was unaware of any of the alleged
Russian connection
he called Twitter's actions to
deactivate his site a chilling effort to
strip him of the right of free speech
and a warning to all that they could be
next
mr. da bomb room had originally agreed
to come on our program tonight and talk
about his organization but today he told
us he is suffering from the flu and
cannot make it we hope you'll join us on
a future date but joining us now from
Washington is Richard Clark one of the
country's preeminent cyber experts the
co-author of the book cyber war and a
national security adviser to both
President Clinton and Bush as well as
chair of President Obama's special
review committee on technology and
intelligence gathering mr. Clark thank
you very much for joining us let me
start by asking you do you think Twitter
did the right thing in suspending the
accounts of the u.s. freedom army I
think Twitter is generally doing the
right thing now when it's informed
usually by others that sites are in
essence Russian BOTS are Russian trolls
the vast volume of what was going on on
that site was obviously by Russian BOTS
and trolls as Dave from Teheran just
said he can demonstrate with his data
and I think all of these social media
sites Facebook Twitter YouTube reddit
they need to take things down as soon as
they know that they're not real people
by the Russian trolls and Russian Box
why do you think the Russians would be
so interested in this rather obscure
group they only have 11,000 people on
their mailing list they they do exist
but it's not that active I suspect there
aren't even 11,000 real people I think
most of those people that are probably
phony Russian names why does Russia want
to do this Putin's told us
Putin has said publicly I want to knock
America down so it's not the world's
superpower anymore and he said I am
almost completed that mission it's
almost done
how does he do it he does it by causing
us
internal dissent when we all go after
each other in his world the best thing
that could possibly happen would be for
violence in the United States and the
message of this freedom army is when
President Trump or someone like him
calls for the uprising to challenge the
deep state that all these people most of
whom are armed by the way they say they
they're armed will rise up and and
challenge the government this is like a
Russian subversive army like a series of
Russian controlled guerrilla cells
stashed throughout the United States and
before you say that's crazy
remember that based on phony Russian
batson controls in the past talking
about pizza parlor in Washington being
the home of nefarious deeds now a man
showed up at that piece of power with an
automatic weapon and thankfully was
arrested only yesterday a United States
Coast Guard officer was arrested with 15
weapons a man who had said there will be
a civil war if Trump is impeached and
who will call that civil war who will
say now is the time Russian BOTS and
trolls on sites like the one you found
so this clearly has continued since the
elections and since the midterm
elections the Russians don't seem to
have stopped based on this information
well they haven't stopped messing around
with the elections either they're
already going after four or five of the
Democratic candidates altering pictures
putting up phony quotes from them it's
only gonna get worse Brian and now that
you can do deep fakes where you can have
audio and video that looked like you or
I are talking but other words are coming
out of our mouths in our voices we're in
for a heck of a year leading up to the
next election we're
and bots and trolls will be doing all
sorts of fakery if there is an attempt
to impeach the president you can bet
that will also be calling on people to
get out their guns
what's the prevention of this how do you
how do you stop this or control it is
there a way well there is a way say
Facebook Twitter the other sites have
the technology just as Dave does to find
out which users are fake which users are
trolls and Bob
richardclark thank you very much we
appreciate you coming on tonight and
giving us your insights it certainly
helps to explain the complex new world
we face and trying to figure out who and
what to believe mr. Clark thank you very
much for joining us thank you Brian
coming up finally there's evidence of
serious vote fraud committed it turns
out on behalf of a Republican candidate
for Congress when we return now claims
by President Trump and other elected
Republican officials about widespread
voter fraud have been repeatedly
debunked but now this week some real
evidence of fraud has finally emerged
accepted involves fraud allegedly
committed by Republicans on behalf of a
Republican candidate for Congress in
North Carolina going to Washington to be
your voice in the ninth congressional
district Republican Mark Harris declared
victory in the congressional election
last November he won by just 905 votes
I've missed allegations his staff had
stuffed the ballot boxes with fraudulent
absentee ballots this week at a special
hearing of the North Carolina State
Election Board those allegations appear
to have been confirmed a campaign worker
Lisa Britt testified she was paid $125
for every 50 absentee ballots she
collected and then filled in for
Republican candidates or throwing away
any marked for Democrats
I assume you knew that it was not I
understand you but you were paid to do
something that you knew was wrong so
it's not like you only since the
election figured out that was wrong you
knew at the time you were voting other
people's ballots it was wrong yes and he
knew was illegal yes and if that weren't
shady enough many of the absentee
ballots that were delivered were signed
by the same eight people including three
of them who signed their name
or than 40 times and I'm being told we
have one of the ballots it was signed by
Hugh gee election fraud late today the
State Election Board of North Carolina
voted unanimously to order a new
election based on the evidence they have
uncovered a voter and election fraud I'm
joined now by Matthew Dunlap the
Secretary of State in Maine and one of
the Democrats appointed to serve on
president Trump's Commission on election
integrity a group that was disbanded
after only two meetings
mr. Dunlap let me ask by asking you
start by what happened in North Carolina
what do you think of that well I think
the bottom line is the process worked in
the end probably not the way we'd would
have wanted to see it work you always
want the voters to have the last say in
terms of who their representatives are
going to be but nonetheless the the
chain of custody procedure is at North
Carolina and so many other states like
Maine employ did went out the day the
the misdoing was discovered and remedy
is unfortunately a new election but the
voters will finally have the last say in
this election you wrote an op-ed in The
Washington Post saying where's the
outrage from those talking about
election fraud what do you mean well
when I was on the presidential Advisory
Commission on election integrity some of
the members were quite strident about
the rampant voter fraud historically
sweeping across the country even though
there's been almost no prosecutions of
such voter misconduct they said that is
nonetheless rampant and that we needed
to tighten up our election laws in order
to prevent voter fraud what we saw in
North Carolina was not voter fraud it
was actually election fraud perpetrated
by election election workers volunteers
and paid consultants not by voters so
what was striking to me was that those
same people that were beating their
chests so vmon lee trying to change
election laws prevent voter fraud had
been very strangely silent about what's
been happening in North Carolina which i
think is actually quite telling but in
terms of a widespread voter fraud did
you find any we found none in fact in
the state of Maine and I've been
Secretary of State this is my third
year we've had two suspected cases of
voter misconduct that were forwarded to
the attorney general's office and they
weren't prosecuted because basically the
people just didn't know what they were
doing they were making mistakes not
trying to commit crimes and I think
that's that's a that's what we see
around the country is confusion not not
criminal misconduct by voters American
citizens care about their elections and
that was borne out in the whole public
discourse around the Commission's work
that I was proud to be a part of
bringing down actually unfortunately we
had a chance to do some good work and it
was completely undermined by this
Phantom Menace that the vampire hunters
keep chasing well this stop thing of
what you think to toughen voter
registration rules and laws I don't
think it will I think that's going to be
an ongoing debate we've been debating it
in Maine and across the country now for
many many years about that balance
between the access of a voter to the
ballot and the security of that ballot
and it is a very fine balance I think we
do a great job across the country and
maintaining those balances some states
take more stringent approaches to these
things than than others and but there's
a reason why a state like Maine for
example is one of the leaders in voter
turnout around the country it's because
we have that access balanced by security
so this notion of widespread voter fraud
you just don't find it at all is it's
sort of like razor blades and apples
around Halloween you hear about it every
year but it never really seems to happen
Matthew Dunn I think that mr. Dunlap
thank you for joining us from Maine
tonight very much appreciate it
coming up on our shout out for the
reporter who travelled north of the
Arctic Circle for a startling
investigation into who has been getting
hired as a police officer when we return
our shout out tonight for one of the few
investigative reporters working in
Alaska a reporter who understood there
was a big story right in front of him
that had been ignored for years
convicted felons who were able to get
jobs as police officers in some of the
state's remote villages places where
until recently few reporters ever showed
up my name is Kyle Hopkins I'm a
reporter and the editor for the
Anchorage Daily News in Anchorage Alaska
a lot of the stories that we want to
cover and a lot of the best stories are
in these are plum villages that are hard
hard for us to get to there are all
these small communities with all these
small governments and they work in the
shadows they just do they do what they
like because there's there's no one
paying attention because their
communities just are not large enough to
support on the local journalism I found
that again and again you would see
someone who had been accused of domestic
violence or you know rape or homicide
and you would also find that that person
had at what point and sometimes still
was serving as a police officer as
Hopkins discovered when he travelled to
this village above the Arctic Circle the
village of Selawik population 850 on a
November night three years ago someone
gave alcohol to 16 year old Lois
Cleveland and then raped her she died
that night and while the medical
examiner called it undetermined reasons
you know they when when velasca State
Troopers investigated they found that
she had handcuff marks on her wrists and
the state police soon determined that
the village police officer who reported
the crime Brent Norton was in fact the
one who committed the crime in an
interview recorded by state police
Norton admitted he had given her liquor
and had sex with her while she was
unconscious
choose
it was not his first crime Hopkins
discovered you know a simple background
check show that he already had been
convicted of bootlegging and he was on
probation for giving alcohol to another
underage girls so you know was had been
you know gone through the criminal
justice system was accused of and found
him guilty of a crime I was still on the
job
used his used his City paycheck to buy
alcohol that thing he then gave this
girl he raped her the young victim's
mother was distraught and then Hopkins
set out in the state capital to ask the
officials in charge if there were other
police officers like Norton convicted of
serious crimes but still on the job and
the response from this brave lips were a
body you know and their job is to keep
track of the stuff was you'll be have no
idea they just they didn't know they
said no one knew that led to a
full-fledged effort by Hopkins and the
Anchorage Daily News to find out why it
felt like it's the story that I had been
missing and had been right for my face
for years that we got them finally we
just finally need to address this that's
that's really how it felt was like you
know we should have done this years ago
let's let's get this done and just tell
people what's going on and he has he is
the recipient this year of a grant from
the nonprofit ProPublica to continue his
reporting as a kind of one-man wrecking
ball against apathy and corruption I
appreciate you know you putting a
spotlight on local reporting it's a job
nobody wants it out here so so it's nice
to talk to somebody about it
so our shout out this week - Kyle
Hopkins and his editors at the Anchorage
Daily News for devoting the time and the
money to stories that make a real
difference no matter how far at law
it takes to get them that's our report
for tonight we'll be back again next
week hope to see you that